uh Rick Ruben I feel like Rick Rubin is
having like another wave actually yeah
well that book he put out is a classic
is that why the book is great I think oh
I got to check this I think yeah the
creative act is a classic I just always
find
it so important at for for people with
such strong set of beliefs and visions
and ideas to put out a book MH let alone
an audio book like you can press play
and just hear Rick Rubin he could die
tomorrow and you can just press play and
hear him talking about pH his belief
system like that's to me is so
underrated yeah the reason why he came
up I thought that was your Guru person
that you were speaking to yeah no no but
I mean I I listen to Rick ruin without
him realizing I'm listening to him but
okay so what does Rick Rubin do for
those of us that you know he's
synonymous with music but we don't
exactly know what he is doing that's the
guy in the room who only has
the purest intentions at heart which is
I just want this to be the best thing it
could be and so people in the music
business have called him like a reducer
I think Kan they called him a reducer
not a producer you bring him in and he
just sort of like nah cut that out that
should go that should he's just I don't
know it's like you very rarely meet
people who are The Source yeah we talk
about it like me and um BB relli who I
had her at the house for like a month
and a half when I was making Santiago
who says BB burelli she's incredible
she's the one who wrote uh [__] better
have my money by RNA she's an incredible
songwriter incredible songwriter and she
just just gives so many gems in the
studio one of the one of the terms she
kept saying was the source and Pure
Source Pure Source pure and kind of how
she puts it and I agree it's like
there's people who are just the source
they're the source of the sauce like
they're in there just Conjuring the
ideas and then there's people who
deliver the ideas but there's people who
no one knows who are like we're the ones
coming up with the ideas like would you
say Kanye is a source or I would say
Kanye is a source I would also say Rick
ruin is a source okay I think like
people like CIA you know the the pop
singer she's a source that's someone who
people call on her to write their songs
you the way I interpreted Rick from the
book and just from a bunch of his
interviews I'm curious what you think is
like he he seems like a creative
psychologist or like a creative
therapiste it's like creative selfhelp
yeah like you're you're coming to him
being like look I have all these ideas
and I feel really strongly about these
different things but it's all kind of
nebulous and he would be like this is
where you should focus your energy this
is true this energy you're feeling is
honest and will connect with people I'm
always skeptical of of these types of
people but I have so much respect for
the people that admire him so I I give
him that benefit of the doubt
was anywhere anybody else I'd be like
what's this hustle
bro but I'm skeptical of a lot of them
but i' I've had a lot of benefit from a
lot but isn't that how it go good and
bades isn't that how it goes with anyone
like absent of credentials aren't you
skeptical of anyone in everyone always
right so it's like yeah Rick rubben
absent of credentials you're like what
I'm not skeptical if you could dunk from
the free throw line I'm not skeptical if
you're putting up 50 see so it's like if
you know so much about making Ruben has
tangible like you could be like 99
problems and and and all these amazing
yeah but Jay had plenty of hits prior to
of course but but once again it's never
he writing the music for it or is he
there going this is what like I think I
think you know what it is it's tough for
non-musician weers we don't know what it
takes to make understand the
contribution that people who maybe don't
play an instrument or don't write lyrics
Right have but Phil Jackson I don't know
if the triangle offense is that
effective but he can take the ego as the
talent there was a time moved to the
three-point line the triangle offense
was incredibly effective the game passed
him by but he was incredibly he was
effective with the Lakers until 201 11
was Kobe's last championship 2010 but
the three-point line didn't really
change the way that people shot threes
has changed you understand my point he
takes the talent that can dunk from the
free throw line he goes here's how you
win a championship Jordan doesn't win
one before what I'm trying to say is I
I'm not trying to discredit his ex's and
those game I don't want to get too far
off from this but like the the triangle
offense was something that was amazing
now most NBA teams run one of two
offenses it's it's kind of the same
thing it's how you manage those players
which is what you're saying but it was
something novel and unique and really
cool what he was doing there was value I
think why I like resonate with Rick
Rubin so much is because he preaches uh
authenticity and making music for you
the audience that is you yeah and doing
it for that reason and there is no such
thing as writers block because writers
block is either you not being good
enough for yourself or you not being
good enough for them just like there's a
lot of things that he just talks about
that regardless if he had credentials
what he's saying is the truth got it you
know what I'm saying like some people it
doesn't M like I don't like I don't know
y'all from a can of paint right but
y'all can say things that are just the
truth it doesn't matter if I know
y'all's resume you know when you hear
you know the truth you know and I think
the truth just rings out regardless if
there's a resume attached to it and I
think also with him um it's just it's
just it's it's somebody who's looking
out for the artist bro it's like I just
feel like a lot of people are not giving
game on really how like you said a
self-help for creatives it's [__]
incredible what he's doing so I I'm all
for it I'm all yeah I almost look at him
like in a way like Tony Robin is where
it's like he can go into a business or
work with an individual and all the
people that have worked with him
publicly that talk about him Bill Clin
you know Agy they're like yo this guy
changed my life he helped my business he
helped me see the world more clearly and
it seems like Rick does that for
musicians artists and the the contrib
and to add on to that the contribution
factor of someone who like for people
who don't make music it's man it it
would be so incredible to have somebody
in the studio who's knowledgeable who's
a Visionary who has great taste who has
no skin in the game right that's and who
has no bias because I'm in there by
myself most of the time and so I'm
judging super hard or it's me and boas
my best friend and like we both just
like love everything we do and yeah
certain certain songs get this reaction
certain songs but still it's like to
have somebody sort of over here who's
like I don't [__] know y'all at all
yeah this is the one this isn't the one
like I when I met Rick ruin in
2016 um went to his house and we drove
in his car he was driving this I never
it was like a white range overover we're
driving down PCH and I'm playing him
songs and I play him a bunch of songs
and I get to what they want and I don't
know if what they want had come out yet
but for context like what they want is
like five times Platinum now and I
remember playing it a bunch of songs
from what they want comes on and he just
instantly like ears perk up and he's
like this is the one oh wow and this is
like oh wow you know this dude at that
time was in his probably in his 50s
something so it's like not quote unquote
tapped in to the youth and what would
work with the youth and I was 22 23 at
the time I remember listening to that
song and being so upset you were
white and I couldn't believe this white
but he would like Rick was like yo this
is the one you know and it's just like
you know you can do that with a premise
like you can hear a premise now at this
point in comedy and go think that's a
great that's a great I feel like I could
do that with music no [__] I think I
I mean dead ass like I feel like you
play me the album yeah this is a single
well here's the thing here's the thing
that he preaches which like no but
here's the thing that he preaches which
I absolutely subscribe to because it
just feels like the truth which is how
hard is it like ear they make the
decision for you like but you're right
you're right because guess what he talks
about he about in his J Shetty interview
when you take a bite of food how long
does it take for you to say do I like it
or not it's Instinct yeah like same [__]
with music he was like it's just taste I
don't have to think about whether I like
it or not and so Rick Rubin has gotone
to where he is off of his Taste and to
me that is the flyest [__] ever that
dude that dude has got so you would love
Rick Ruben as the point bro you I think
I would I just I am often times
skeptical when I hear about these
figures and the way that they're
described right because what a lot of
times I think that they're like for
example it's really nice to have
somebody when you're an artist tell you
what you're doing is great when all the
other people around you are trying to
monetize you sure so when the label is
trying to make money off this and the
studio is trying to make money off this
and the people at the recordings trying
to make money off and then somebody who
doesn't need your money cuz he's a
multi-millionaire so many times over
comes over and he's like no I like this
one here you go oh I can there's honesty
here yeah like so I understand the
comfort that must come from that and
also the validation from someone that we
always respect it's just learning about
what that actual skill is I'm ignorant
to him yeah the only thing I know is
that people that I respect really
respect him so figure started Death Jam
which was like the first hip-hop label
yeah yeah so but I'm just trying what
what he what the actual tangible thing
is and this creative consultant having
tast like taste is huge like taste is
everything too that's the thing like
it's not even huge it's everything
the reason why you write the jokes you
write is because your taste says they're
funny yeah and the reason why you're
huge is because there's a lot of other
people who say your taste is my taste
right and also just understanding what
the people have like that's taste yeah
understand what people want it's like
understanding culture and understanding
feeling like that's taste and when you
have taste it's hard to imagine some
people don't have taste and it's also
you can't quantify taste you either have
it or you don't he did his 60 minutes
with Anderson Cooper do you play an
instrument no do you know how this board
works no I know what my ears like mhm
that's taste that's everything though
it's like for me there was a lot of
imposter syndrome still is with
like maybe I'm not the best pianist and
maybe I don't know how to work all the
equipment but I feel like I know so so
well what a smash is bro you know what
fun and like that's just taste and
that's what I've been moving off so for
me Rick Rubin is it's just confirmation
that taste is everything I'mma tell my
wife this [__] Bro there we go now we
said you got into the real I just got
it's like his wife has been watching
Rick
Ruben I got taste bab so he's like I get
it I don't know how to pick the things
out I just know when I don't want it I
know when it's not there and I know when
it does hit me it's there but I just
know and I have a really strong opinion
about these things that's interesting
calling it taste yeah that's what it is
reason wore your
clothes no but it's like like the way he
explains it it's so true it's like do
you like this food I don't like it just
tastes it's not like you put on what you
put on right now he really doesn't
understand food it's like a real
sensitive no but this he's he hurts me
this guy hurts he really hurts me we
wear what we want to wear we listen to
what we want to listen to we eat what we
want to eat we date who we want to date
because that's our taste taste dictates
all of our expression and when our tast
is confirmed by millions of people
objectively you could say I have great
taste Rick ruin has great taste prix.com
guys and if you use the promo code
Schultz they will match your initial
deposit up to $100 so you put up 100 you
get a$ 100 for free why don't you gamble
with $100 free doar price.com now let's
get back to the show